[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein richtig
leckeres rezept und zwar gibt es einen
lachs spinat nudel ja eigentlich schon
auf lauf als ein lachs spinat
nudelauflauf aus dem ofen und ich mag
ofen rezepte richtig gerne denn mal
bereitet sie kurz zu gibt sie in den
ofen und in der zeit kann man einfach
was anderes machen also auf was ziemlich
schnelles und einfaches und ich zeige
euch jetzt mal ganz kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier 500 gramm nudeln die habe
ich bereits etwas abgekocht dann habe
ich hier 500 gramm lachs und zwar ist es
aus dem tiefkühlfach 500 gramm spinat
auch aus dem tief gefragt für die sahne
soße habe ich 400 gramm sahne zwei gramm
schmandt etwas oregano etwas dill 2
knoblauchzehen salz und pfeffer und
natürlich etwas gouda käse die nudeln
disneys bereits bisschen abgekocht und
zwar habe ich diese etwa vier minuten
kochen lassen also diese noch al dente
und bissfest also so würde ich sie jetzt
mit soße zum beispiel noch nicht essen
die wären wir noch ein bisschen zu bis
west es gebe ich dir da rein und ich
habe sie gerade eben noch mal unter
kaltes wasser gehalten damit sie einfach
nicht so sehr zusammenkleben und ich
habe jetzt hier eine auflaufform die
habe ich jetzt bereits mit etwas öl
eingestrichen
dann stelle ich das kurz zur seite und
nehme schon mal den lachs und den
schneide ich jetzt in kleine würfel
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich ganz vergessen die
zitrone zu erwähnen denn jetzt marin
ihre ich das lachsfilet noch mit etwas
zitrone salz und pfeffer einfach schön
darüber geben also der saft einer halben
zitrone reichte auch auf jeden fall
und jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
[Musik]
und einfach einmal kurz durch rühren
jetzt gebe ich den lachs direkt über die
nudel einfach gut verteilen
[Musik]
und darüber verteile ich jetzt den
spinat das jetzt noch nicht ganz
aufgetaut aber das macht gar nichts aber
ihr könnt ihn wie gesagt auch komplett
auftauen lassen
und wenn ihr kein tiefkühl spinat habt
um zb frischen spinat müsst ihr einfach
kurz in heißem wasser blanchieren also
kurz abkochen und könnte den dann auch
benutzen
aber so hat man die zutaten meistens
immer alle zu hause und kann das rezept
eigentlich jederzeit machen
[Musik]
jetzt bereite ich hier drin kurz die
soße zu dir geht auch ziemlich schnell
dafür gebe ich jetzt den schmand hier
rein und verrühren mit der sahne erstmal
nur ein becher dann geht es nämlich
einfacher und dann kommt noch der zweite
becher mit dazu jetzt schreibe ich die
knoblauchzehen mit rein
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt noch einen halben
esslöffel den und inhalten esslöffel
oregano mit rein und richtig gut passt
übrigens auch meerrettich mit rein
seit ich beim letzten mal auch mit drin
aber jetzt habe ich gerade keine da und
jetzt wird sich das ganze richtig gut
mit salz und pfeffer
also da könnte auch ordentlich würzen
denn die nudeln und der spinat die haben
jetzt im moment noch keinen geschmack
deswegen ruhig euro nicht als 18 mal
rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kießig die soße direkt über
den ganzen auflauf
[Musik]
und dann fehlt jetzt nur noch die
geriebenen käse
[Musik]
und so kommt der auflauf jetzt für in
den vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad
für etwa 35 minuten und danach lasse ich
ihn kurz abkühlen und zeigen euch gleich
[Musik]
so das essen ist jetzt fertig pünktlich
zu samira ankunft denn sie kam es gerade
vom ballett und jetzt können das
anrichten und muratow kann schon mal
einen teller holen ja welchen
irgendeiner wird sich den heftigen winde
auf wohlstand erhalten und wir schneiden
das ist schon mal ich habe es hier
übrigens einfach so etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten stehen lassen hier damit einfach
hier ein bisschen abkühlt und eben alles
schön gleich zusammen raus kommt weil
wenn man das direkt aus der form raus
nimmt dann läuft alles so ein bisschen
weg und so wird einfach nur mal bitte
fest
ja das ist demokratie
[Gelächter]
aber das ist eigentlich das thema tja
was soll das schon nicht hässlich statt
2000 straßen
ich liebte und lachs und spinat ist für
mich so eine kombination die muss man
einfach lieben
lecker das aussieht so moratti hat der
marktrat so darf ich das mal probieren
hmm gut
natürlich natürlich man kann es
natürlich auch stadt der falle
andere nudeln nehmen zb auch tagliatelle
da gibt es auch diese grünen
man kann eigentlich alles nehmen was man
gerade da hat einfallen morath oder
fällt nein ich bin hier so verfallen
man kann auch panama und dann sagen
willst du mit mir penner
da gab es mal so eine werbekampagne
ich geb dir gleich was zu trinken und
ihr könnt es rezepte nachlesen sallys
blog.de da steht es noch mal ganz genau
und für mich ist es einfach ein leckeres
rezept ich liebe es einfach in den ofen
warte in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal im tischdecken und salat zum
beispiel machen und dann ist das essen
fertig und man hat einfach nicht so viel
arbeit also wenn jetzt nach machen wollt
dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachkochen und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder bis bald was war das
mal vorstellen was mit ein bisschen
gorgonzola zu verfeinern
das stimmt ja dass wir auch noch toll
aber ich wollte ja dein meerrettich
reinmache aber da war leider abgelaufen
ach so ja stimmt ja auch aber schon
jetzt abschalten
löwenzahn abschalten
[Musik]